If you're going to be working with
Windows as a user or as an administrator
of the system, you will find a number of
useful utilities are located in the
Windows Control Panel. Here's our
Windows 11 desktop. And this is very
similar to the way that Windows 10 would
operate as well. To start the control
panel, we'll go down to the search
option. We'll start typing in control.
And you can see it fills in and puts
control panel right at the top. If we
select that, we then see our control
panel options. By default, the list of
options available in the control panel
are shown in a category mode. This does
hide a number of the names associated
with the different control panel
applets. So, I'll tend to change the
view from category to something like
small icons or the one that I like the
most, the large icons. This allows you
to see every utility associated with the
control panel and they are all listed in
alphabetical order. One of the control
panel applets you'll need to know about
is the one for internet options. This
provides you with a list of options that
are available from your builtin internet
browser. You'll notice that there is
information about browsing history on
this general tab. You have information
about how you want the browser to appear
as far as colors and language and fonts.
And then you have information about what
is displayed in the individual tabs.
Under the security tab, we have the
options to define what particular rights
and permissions are allowed depending on
where we're connected to the internet.
For example, if we are on an internet
zone, then you will have much more
security than if you're somewhere on a
local internet zone. You can also set
rights and permissions if you are
connecting to a site that you consider
to be trusted and a different set of
options if this is a restricted site.
The privacy tab inside of our internet
properties allows us to allow or
disallow access to certain sites and how
we might deal with the cookies
associated with that site. And we also
have the option here to change how the
pop-up blocker will work inside of our
browser. The content tab gives us
information about how certificates are
handled inside of the browser and it
turns on or turns off the autocomplete
process. If you're connecting to the
internet over something other than a
direct connection, you may want to
modify some of the settings within the
connections tab. This is how you can set
up an internet connection that might be
dialup or through a VPN. And you can put
all of those parameters into these
settings. This is also where you might
want to define a proxy server, assuming
it's a proxy server that does not work
in a transparent mode. You'll find that
information under LAN settings, and
you'll see there is an option here for
automatic configuration of those proxy
settings, or you can manually specify a
proxy server and add the address
yourself. The next option in our
internet settings is for programs. This
defines how add-ons are configured
inside of your browser to extend the
capabilities of the browser itself. We
can also define certain programs that
will be used by default if you're
clicking on particular links on a web
page. And lastly, we have the option for
advanced. This is a detailed list of
configuration settings that allows you
to modify the ways that accessibility is
used in the browser. We have information
about the type of protocols that might
be used and you can define how the
browser will react depending on what
type of site you're
visiting. There may be times when you
need to configure settings on a printer
or modify the way a particular device is
configured. One of the ways to access
these configuration parameters is
through the option for devices and
printers. Anything you're connecting to
across the network or devices that are
directly connected to your computer will
be found in this devices and printers
window. This is a very useful front end,
especially for users that need access to
the configuration parameters of a
device, but they don't want to have to
go through the detailed breakdown that's
available inside of device manager. You
can even see that the icons within
devices and printers make it very easy
to identify and select devices that are
on your network.
In my control panel, I simply select
devices and printers. And you can see a
number of different devices appear. Some
of these devices get a generic icon.
Other devices are identified as a
microphone and it shows an icon of a
microphone or a printer. And you can see
the specific printer names are listed
underneath. If you want to modify any of
these, you can right mouse click on any
of these devices, configure the options,
or change some of the properties of the
printer associated with that icon.
Often when you're installing
applications, it's a single application
installation program that you're using
that you may have downloaded directly
from the internet. But if you'd like a
summary of all of the applications that
have been installed on your computer,
you can choose the option for programs
and features. This will show you all of
the installations that you've made. And
from here, you can choose to uninstall
or reinstall different aspects of that
application. This gives you a list of
all of the applications that are
installed. You can see the date that
you've installed it on and how much size
it's taking on your drive. You can also
right mouse click on these applications
and choose to uninstall the app to
remove it from your computer. There's
also an option on this programs and
features page to turn Windows features
on or off. And if we click on that
option, it will list a number of
different Windows features. You can see
there is a large number of them listed.
So if you wanted to install a new
feature, for example, you wanted to
install internet information services
hostable web core or you wanted to
uninstall features such as the media
features, you can click on that category
and click okay, and it will either
install or uninstall those
features. If you're doing any type of
network troubleshooting, then you'll
probably spend some time inside of the
network and sharing center control panel
outlet. This covers not just your wired
network connections, but your wireless
connections as well. And from inside of
this list, you can choose to look at
detailed configurations of every network
adapter. In the control panel, you'll
find network and sharing center is
listed. In this particular case, I have
a single active network connection. It's
an Ethernet connection. And if I click
that, it will bring up the Ethernet
status. And from here, I can see exactly
how this particular Ethernet adapter is
configured. If you'd like more details
about the properties of that adapter,
you can click the properties option and
it brings up a list of all of the
different configurations for that
adapter. For example, if you wanted to
see the IP version 4 information for
this adapter, we can simply click on
that option and choose properties. From
here, you can see the IP address, subnet
mask, any DNS server configurations, or
you can see if this adapter has already
been configured for DHCP.
When you first sit down at a Windows
computer, it may not be obvious what
specific version of Windows is
configured in this system. Under the
control panel, you can choose the system
outlet and get an overview of the system
configuration, including the addition of
Windows that's running with the version
information, and you can see information
about the hardware configuration,
including the processor, installed RAM,
and other details of the operating
system. In our Windows 11 control panel,
we'll choose the option for system. This
will bring up a separate window which
shows us in the main window information
about this system. We also have options
along the left sidebar that gives us
details into information such as
Bluetooth and devices, apps, accounts,
gaming accessibility, and other options.
You'll also notice in the middle of the
page are related links. You can view
domain or workg groupoup information for
this device, view the system protection
settings. If you choose the advanced
system settings option, it launches a
different dialogue box for the system
properties. And under the advanced tab,
you have options to change the
performance of this system, including
things like visual effects and virtual
memory. If you would like to change how
much virtual memory is being used by
your system, you can click that settings
option and choose the advanced tab
within those performance options. Inside
of here, you can change the virtual
memory paging file. You can decide how
large that file is and if you want to
make changes to that, you can modify it
inside of the virtual memory dialogue
box. Like many operating systems,
Microsoft includes a firewall that is
built into the Windows OS. This is
called the Windows Defender Firewall,
and this allows you to prevent access to
your computer from outside of your
system. This is separated into two
different categories. one for the
private networks that you may be
connected to and another one if you're
connected to a guest or a public
network. For example, you might have a
completely different set of security
policies if you're inside of your
private network, but the moment you go
to a coffee shop or connect externally
to an internet connection, you may want
to use a different set of security
features. This is something integrated
into Windows and turned on by default.
So you don't have to do anything extra
to use the capabilities inside of
Windows Defender Firewall. If you want
to make changes to any of these
settings, you can find it under the
control panel in Windows
Firewall. You'll find the firewall
settings under the control panel items
and Windows Defender Firewall is listed
under one of those applets. You can see
that it launches all of the
configurations for the Windows Defender
Firewall. And since this device is also
connected to a Windows domain, we have a
different set of security policies that
we can set when we're connected to a
domain network. Notice that we have a
number of options along the left side to
turn on and off the firewall, restore
the defaults in case you happen to
enable a feature that blocks important
traffic, and then you have advanced
settings that you can choose. And we
will go into the advanced settings of
Windows Firewall in a future video.
An icon you might not see inside of your
control panel is the mail outlet. This
applet will not appear unless you have
installed a supported email client. For
example, if you've installed Microsoft
Outlook onto your computer, then the
mail icon will appear in your control
panel. If it does appear, you can start
it and get options of setting up email
accounts and directories, modifying the
data files that are used by that email
client, or setting up particular
profiles for your email settings. If you
choose the email accounts option, you'll
be presented with a number of email
accounts that have been configured on
the system and you can enable, disable,
or change the properties of each of
those accounts. You also have an option
for data files inside of that link where
you can define where the files are being
stored for all of your email. If you
find that this is taking up too much
room at the location where it's
currently located, you can change the
location of that file and redirect
everything to that new directory.
These days, we rely on not only hearing
information coming from our computer,
but we often need to input sound into
our computer, usually using a
microphone. You can manage both the
input and output of sound from the sound
outlet within the control panel. This
allows you to modify playback options,
such as your speakers, or you can choose
the recording tab and modify options for
your microphone. If you have multiple
playback devices or multiple recording
devices, you can specify which one of
those devices will be the primary or
default settings under the sound
outlet. Your control panel also has an
option for your local user accounts.
These would be accounts that are stored
on your local computer and they're not
part of your active directory domain.
From here, you can modify or add account
name information and specify the type of
account that this might be. For example,
you can configure an account to be a
regular user or an administrator
account. This is also where you would go
to change things like the password
associated with this account or modify
the icon representing this account name.
And if you're doing some type of file
encryption on the system, you can manage
those encryption certificates from the
user accounts outlet. Let's bring up the
user accounts on this computer. By
default, it will show the user account
that is currently logged in. And in this
case, it is the professor account. From
here, you can change things associated
with your account control so that you
can define when the account control
settings would appear on your screen.
You can also choose the option to manage
all user accounts on this system. On
this particular computer, you can see
that I only have one user on this
computer and that user is myself
configured as both a user and an
administrator. If I want to modify the
file encryption certificates, we can
choose that option on the left side and
you can modify how those encryption
certificates are stored on your
system. The Windows operating system
doesn't know how to interact with any of
the hardware on your system unless there
is a device driver that makes that
connection between the operating system
and the hardware. You would find this
list of device drivers under the Windows
device manager in your control panel.
This will allow you to add devices,
remove devices, or modify configuration
settings specific to these device
drivers. This will tell you if Windows
is able to see and use that piece of
hardware, and you'll be able to make
detailed configuration changes if you
need
to. Inside of our control panel, we can
choose the option for device manager.
This will bring up a separate window
with a list of all of the device
categories for our system. You can see
for example there are cameras, disc
drives, keyboards, print cues, printers,
system devices, and a lot more. Let's
look at configuration settings for
things like our display adapter. You can
see this is a parallels display adapter.
And if I right mouse click on it, I can
choose to update the driver, disable the
device, uninstall that device driver, or
scan for any changes that we may have
made to the hardware. If we look at the
properties for this device driver, we
will see a similar set of properties for
this and other devices on our network.
It has a general tab, a driver tab,
details, events, and resources. The
general tab gives us information on what
this device happens to be. This will
give us a summary of what this device
is. And you can see under the device
status, it will tell us if the Windows
operating system is able to use that
device properly. Under the driver tab,
you can view details for this specific
device driver. This is the driver date
and the driver version. And if you
wanted to know exactly what files are
associated with this driver, you can
click on driver details and it shows you
the entire Windows path for that system
file. The next tab over shows us
information about the details for this
driver. In this case, we only have one
value associated with this device
driver. If you're wondering if this
device driver has ever been updated, you
can click the events tab and it shows
you every event associated with this
device driver through the years. And
lastly, we have the resources tab that
tells us exactly memory ranges,
interrupts, and other important hardware
information about the configuration of
this device
driver. If you ever search for things at
the search menu within your Windows, you
may notice that you get responses back
very quickly. It's able to find detailed
information that may be hidden within a
file that's well inside of your
operating system. So, how is Windows
able to find that information so
quickly? That's because Windows has
already gone through the process of
indexing all of those files on your
system and it's simply referencing that
index to be able to quickly find that
information. If you'd like to modify how
Windows is providing that index, you can
change that configuration under the
indexing options.
Under the control panel, we choose the
option for indexing options. It opens up
a new window and inside of this window,
you can see the default settings. It's
going to include locations for your
start menu and under our users folder.
It's going to index everything in those
particular folders unless we have set
specific exclusions for different types
of folders. If you'd like to modify
those, you can click the modify option
at the bottom and change the specific
folders that are being indexed or not
indexed on your computer. Perhaps we'd
like to index all of these folders, but
instead specify certain types of files
that we don't want to index. Under the
advanced option, we can choose the file
types tab and we can select exactly what
type of files would be good to index and
what type of files we do not want to
include in that search
index. If you're a system administrator,
there are a number of utilities inside
of the control panel that can help you
monitor and maintain this computer.
You'll find them under a setting called
administrative tools, or in most recent
Windows versions, it's called Windows
tools. Inside of this Windows tools
section might be options for computer
management, registry editing, task
manager, task scheduler, and much more.
The administrative tools or windows
tools can be found in the control panel.
It will either be listed as
administrative tools or on later
versions of Windows, you'll find the
option for Windows tools. This will
bring up a separate window that gives us
a list of administrative functions that
we can use to keep this system up and
running.
The Windows file explorer allows us to
access individual files and folders on
our system. And there are a number of
different options you can configure from
the file explorer options inside of your
control panel. One of these might be the
general options where you can configure
how the folders can be browsed when you
click an item, what happens, and you can
specify privacy options as well.
You'll find the file explorer options
under that named link inside of your
control panel and it will bring up a
separate window with three tabs across
the top for general view and search. The
general tab determines how file explorer
can be used. Not only what's shown in
the different windows, but what happens
when you single click or doubleclick a
particular file. Under the view tab, you
have the option to customize what is
displayed or what is hidden inside of
the file explorer. And lastly, under the
search tab, you can make changes to what
information will be searched in file
explorer. You can choose whether to
include system directories, whether you
would like to look into compressed files
such as zip files to find information
within those compressed files. And you
can specify whether you're going to look
at just the file names or whether you're
going to look into the detailed content
of every
file. Windows also gives us access to
many power options not only for our
laptop computers, but we can also change
power options on our desktop computers
as well. You'll find these options under
the control panel under the option
marked power options. For example, you
might be able to set a configuration
where your system will hibernate. That
means it will take all of the open
documents that you're using and all of
the applications in use and will save
that information to the drive associated
with your system. This is very common on
laptop computers because it will save
everything to disk and even if you lose
the battery power, you will still be
able to recover where you left off. This
is something that's commonly used by the
fast startup feature inside of Windows
as well. Since it does take a number of
seconds to be able to pull the
information off of your storage drive
and put it back into memory when you
power on your system, you may instead
want to choose the sleep or standby
option. Instead of taking your
applications and your data and moving it
to a storage drive, it simply keeps
everything in the memory of your system.
This requires constant power to be able
to maintain that particular state.
Although it is not a lot of power, it
can still take away from the battery on
your system. If you're planning to swap
out your battery or the battery that
you're using is very low, you might want
to use the hibernate function instead.
And this also gives you a great deal of
customization over how every component
inside of Windows is using
power. In our control panel, we would
choose the option for power options. And
this tells us that there are two current
power plans that you can choose from.
one that is labeled balanced and the
other one that is labeled parallels. So
if we would like to change how the
display is powering off, we can wait
five minutes, we can wait 45 minutes or
customize the exact time that we would
like to use. And if you never want the
display to turn off, you can choose the
option for never. You can also have the
system automatically put itself to
sleep. And again, if you'd like to make
it so this system never goes to sleep
automatically instead of setting a
specific time frame, you can select the
option for never. If you'd like to have
even more granularity for the power
settings, you can choose the advanced
power settings, which opens up a
separate window. And from here, you can
modify settings for the hard disk, for
background settings, the sleep options,
PCI Express settings, and settings for
your display. If you're on a laptop,
this allows you to also customize what
happens when you close the top lid of
your laptop. Does the laptop stay on? Do
you put it into a sleep mode or
hibernate mode? You get to control that
from the power options. You can also
change settings for your USB interfaces.
You may have devices connected to your
computer that need to always maintain
power from the USB port, and you can
configure and manage that process inside
of power options. You also have the
option to change the way your system is
starting up. There's a Windows feature
called fast startup that's able to bring
Windows up and running very quickly when
you press the power button to turn on.
In reality, it's able to provide this
faster startup process because Windows
never technically completely shuts down.
If you need to completely shut down your
operating system each time you turn it
off, you may want to turn off those fast
startup settings within the power
options in the control panel.
And Windows also includes a number of
accessibility features that allows you
to use the operating system even easier.
In the control panel, you'll find these
options inside the ease of access
center. In here, you can do things like
start a magnifier, change your onscreen
keyboard options, have a narrator that
tells you what's on the screen, or set
up a high contrast display option. So,
if you need a little bit of extra help
in using your operating system, you
might find some very useful features
inside the ease of access center.